عندما يتعلق الأمر
معاملة التبادل والرسائل المتضاربة لها
رسائل
قاطرات رفيعة المستوى رفيعة المستوى وهناك رسائل من مسؤولين رفيعي المستوى
الإسرائيليون، أنا أصدق الرسائل
بايبر كالعادة
الخبر الصحيح لا يأتي من خارج البلاد
بسرعه
عذراً يا أعضاء الكنيست
شيكي يمكننا أن نسمح له بمواصلة الحديث
بعد ذلك نسمع تعليقات وصيحات ولكن أولا
نعم من فضلك اعذرني كيلي شيكلي بعض الناس أنا
أوافق على أنه سيكون هناك منافسي، فأنت لا تستحق ذلك
كاحلي وكاحلي أصدقائي أنتم تستحقون الازدراء
أنت مغنية دون المستوى، مغنية صغيرة، مغنية متواضعة، مغنية ليس لها صوت
انظر ماذا تفعل بينج بونج بك
لقد وضعتك من فم إلى فم وأعطيتني فمين
ن
أنت أجنبي، أنا وأنت
[تصفيق]
مرحبا